if you recall I did say that every
single one of these has it equivalence
in explore gives your log Lord okay I'm
not going to do every single one we
don't need every single one some of them
are just as you put it out why'd you go
to just versions of themselves just
rewritten inside a different way just so
you look faster I'm only going to pull
out a cup of water but more importantly
than that I sort of want to try and give
you a bit of intuition for how logs work
by giving you what for me was kind of
like a you remember what I showed you
I'll try to convince you of this right
when we're doing arithmetic and algebra
at the beginning of this year this
identity you're so very familiar with
and what I tried to do was approach it
visually right but you don't have to
approach it visually but it's a nice
easy way to splash yourself with a
better set of course that's not as great
plus b-squared because you're missing
this do you remember that so it's just
another way to think about it and if for
one useful - you can just put it to one
side and you can do just remember that
if you're happy with it okay
I kind of want to do a similar thing for
logs before I launch into the bit of
four I just want to ask this one here
they're really sick words it's not
obviously oh is that even a law if I
wrote this in a log law instead of an
index though what would it be quite yeah
look it is a log base a on a equals one
okay I'm happy with that now let me try
to explain the better form right I'm
going to do this instead of with hours
where I'm just going to do with this
concrete numbers but I'm going to refer
to these balls constantly okay so
underneath where you've written all this
I just want you to maybe make the
subheading of like a medical I've always
need support
now like I said to make it a little
easier for your render process I'm going
to give this to you numerically so if
you just consider this simple equation
this statement here right I'm just
picking numbers that your mind can be
comfortable with this is a statement
that is basically about an object that
grows it grows for a certain amount of
time and it ends up at this other size
okay so think about this are the red
things growing up just have a look at
the number that I've chosen right this
is an object that is doubling doubling
and doubling and doubling it does this
so this amount of time if it doubles to
that long
this is how bigger will end up do you
agree with that deserve accepts that's
if you have a machine it could double
something you put in there for five
minutes you first started you know life
came on and spun around to do with Dean
and then it came out perfectly of
machines big enough is three times
bigger than when it started makes it
okay now think about this figure out how
this works with all of these guys over
here if I said to you this they're just
poor German do not say what the answer
is
just think about what my metaphor would
mean this should mean I've got a machine
it's a doubling machine right how long
has it been in the machine for what
would this mean in terms of time this
made you wait five minutes you end up
five minutes in the future right what
would this mean means you go back in
time five minutes ago
five minutes ago how big was your thing
and now you know if the answer is right
what if the answer
what does that mean It's Made if you if
you're sitting next to a growing machine
right and you rewind five minutes then
five minutes ago your thing was 32 times
smaller than what it is right now just
that make sense what about this
pause don't say the answer just think
about what it means you've got a growing
machine it doubles for as long as you
put it in there
how long have you put it in there you
haven't you haven't put it in
so how big is it answer it hasn't gotten
bigger hasn't gotten smaller it's the
same if the original size is this slim
fit okay now think about what each of
these would mean
okay I'm missing one sorry this one here
this is like the classic example you
just put it in for a minute you press go
60 seconds later and of course as you
expected it's double size because that's
what it's listed right now what would
each of these look like in terms of laws
how would you rewrite this you can look
over here if you want if we would help
you how did you rewrite this as a log
equation not as an exponential equation
log base two just pause there you're
going to have to do a lot of this
conversion back and forth between
Exponential's and logs what you might
find is a nice anchor point is the base
in your exponential equation that's why
I keep saying at this particular way the
base in your exponential credit is a
base of your log equation okay so you
long as you know where that is you'll
mostly get the rest of it right one
place to of what now just pause just
pause you know from the original
equation the first one I wrote down what
two and five and thirty two are what
they stand for what they signify the two
is how fast is this lead growing the
five is how long it's been in there like
a time and then the 32 is what it was
the result is how long gets now these
restate numbers right too much like
you're growing rich this is how big your
thing ends up so the answer is what's
the last numbers left it's fine so in
other words if you compare these two
equations right the exponential equation
once it telling you it's saying if you
don't have fastest thing grows and how
long it's going for I'll tell you how
big it ends up I'll tell you whether it
ends up bigger or smaller or the same or
a bit bigger does that make sense
more equations are dealing with this
same situation the same machine the same
scenario but they utter different
questions instead of asking how fast how
long they say how fast and where we end
up I'll tell you how long it takes
does that make sense think about how you
rewrite each of these strengths if I
said this now you can see what the
number is right you can see just where
it comes from over here but what does it
mean it means if you are going at this
rate and you want to be smaller than
what you are now right then you need to
go look forwards in time but batteries
by the way it also explains why just as
a bit of a side note we do take this
because it's a law that doesn't make
sense
what if I said to you this what would it
mean
what's your machine being asked to do
this is a growing machine right we've
already established that if you want to
get smaller you have to go back in time
well how far back in time do you have to
go to your object is not smaller and
smaller than smaller but just ceases to
exist answer your machine can't do that
right it can't turn nothing into
something and it can't turn something
into nothing either to go back in time
that's life this this is not defined
right in the same way what about
something like this love to own anything
need something like that what would that
mean
we again it's a growing and shrinking
machine right it'll get bigger it'll get
smaller but it's not going to like
suddenly go into some other dimensional
nothing's oh you can't do that right so
again this is not defined because
thinking about what's the situation
isn't what it's doing right okay how
about this one how would you rewrite it
log base 2 of in other words you're a
growing machine but you don't want it to
get bigger or smaller you just want its
original size so what do you do well you
don't put in the machine to put it in at
the zero time right and then lastly here
well if you want something to double and
you have a doubling machine then you put
in for one is to that vector so think
about what your numbers are doing and
how they're behaving right I like the
negative Exponential's and logs it's
just look at this same as one situation
get a bigger game smaller either from
the viewer
where are you going to end up will be
your final size or how long would you
like to take to get there that's what
this is all about and it's what explain
things like say this I love this right
look at this what is this mean what does
this mean for our growing machine let's
put some numbers on check let's go say
this one which we just talked to that
plus say this one think about what it
means first before you jump to the air
top numerically okay you put in the
Machine and this thing is about telling
you how long right so by the way how
long is that you already know nice
spamming okay if you put it for five
minutes
and then you put in for a further how
many minutes you put in for another four
minutes so it's been there for nine
minutes this thing's going to be really
big right is doubling for a long time
how big will it end up once you've
doubled it for nine minutes
faculty pounds or two I'm pretty sure
630 times 15 is 512 okay because think
about what it means right if you put in
for this ball and then you put in for
this long guess how big this thing is
going to be and that's know of course
okay just focus or better be nine yes
it's the same with these it's the same
with it's a this one again is instead of
adding like some different ones if I
went log base a of X and log base a of X
again right
think big what is the law tell you just
what it is wall so it's each other it's
just going to be log base a of x squared
why is that and why does it give you
this by the way this is the way you
would sort of stain it colloquially I
should put them bracket can locally you
would say well I would bring this to at
the front right this power becomes the
coefficient but why is that you're doing
the same thing twice so therefore the
first time you've got x times bigger and
then when you did it again
it got x times bigger again well then x
squared times we go
that makes sense logs are about time
that's the idea underneath okay if you
can understand that contact then all of
this is just manipulation it's just
because they do kind of written it it's
just arithmetic with time rather than if
you take in terms of ultimate size which
is what this is over okay